What's up guys, it's Grant here and I'm giving away a Galaxy S9+ smartphone to one of you.
There's a link down the description to get your name on the list to qualify, it's a little subscriber appreciation for you
Love you guys. Appreciate your support, go get your name on the list to get qualified and all the best.
Hey guys. Today, we're gonna be finishing up the gear project that we started in a previous video
We managed to make a mold around a piece of foam using some drywall
Texturing paste and then we stuck that into some sand and we cast copper down into it
We got this great copper gear, but it still looks very messy. So today we're gonna see what it takes to clean this up
We've got a bunch of sandpaper. We've got files. We've got metal brushes
We've got polishing wheels and we've got metal polish and we are just going to hit this thing with everything we've got until
We can get it nice and clean and just shiny. Like I want to be able to see my reflection and then this bad boy
Will it work? I don't know. This is an experiment and we're gonna find out.
I've got a 60 grit belt on our belt sander here
We're gonna see how much of this copper we can smooth down using the belt sander
It might be a little bit tricky because I do have quite a bit to get through before it's nice and smooth
But I think that's gonna be our best tool for this job. If this doesn't work, we'll see about moving on to something else
All right, that's just a few seconds on the belt sander
You can already see the progress we're making we can also see that our copper is apparently like swiss cheese full of holes,
Not exactly sure what caused that or how deep those bubbles go. I'm just going to keep on going
We might be able to sand right through those or maybe one side of our gears can have a really cool
Decoration all over it. Think theres only one way to find out.
Still getting flatter, you still see those holes.
Does look like some of them are pretty shallowing, I think we've almost gone all the way through them
I bet some of them are deep enough that they'll still show up in our final service
But even just that I really like how the copper is starting to show up there. It looks pretty cool
My wheel is also getting nice and hot I'm gonna have to grab some water to cool this off and after a couple minutes of
Sanding because it's gonna get warm doing this, but I'm liking it it's working
I have only been doing this for like less than a minute already and it's definitely making progress
So this sandpaper on the belt sander seems to be the way to go
All right and kind of just like that it is getting
Too warm to hold on to so I'm just gonna get some cold water that I can cool this off in
And dry it off and throw it back on the belt sander
Copper does conduct heat better than
Most if not all metals, it might not be the very best heat conducting metal, but it's really high up there
This has spread so much sanded copper out on the work bench. Look at this. You can just like
Making a pile back to the grind. Literally.
And then we've made pretty good progress on this side, we've definitely flattened it all out
You can see that the shiny copper is exposed all the way through a lot of these bubbles on this side
But I think that's actually going to be a pretty cool looking effect
We'll see how I decide to go about cleaning those up time to move on to the other side
Which is already quite a bit flatter
So I think it'll go pretty quick and we'll see if there's any bubbles on this side, too. I'm not sure yet.
We've got both sides of our gear partially sanded down and they are looking good.
Now I want to try getting into the teeth of this. I'm not gonna be able do that on the belt sander
So I'm gonna move over to our bench vise and start using some hand files
And see if I can clean up those edges a bit.
We may come back to the files in a little bit for some more detail work
But for now, we're gonna move on to using the wire brushes on this rotary tool
And we've got something that should fit in our regular drill chuck
So we'll try and see if we can clean up some of the edges that are harder to hit with a file
This little attachment may not be the sturdiest built thing ever
I think 60% of the wires have just torn themselves off polishing that copper right there
At the end of the drill I now have what is a wheel made of cotton or maybe muslin disks
And then I've got some polish which I will apply to the cloth
and then I'll use that to try and really bring out a nice shine on the copper
My goal is to make a copper gear so shiny that I could see myself
How do you think I did? This method of casting copper is not 100 percent perfect
By pouring it in the way
We did we ended up with a lot of large bubble marks on the backside and a lot of small ball marks on the front
side
but it was still able to be flattened down smoothed out and
Polished and like I could use this thing as a copper colored mirror. It's a little small, but overall it looks really good.
Hey, what's up guys it is Grant here, with a brand new Galaxy S9+ smartphone that I'm giving away to one of you for
Subscriber appreciation. I've got a link down in the description so you can get your name on the list and qualify to win.